joining us now for reaction from Roanoke
Virginia is Republican Congressman Bob
Goodlatte he's the chairman of the House
Judiciary Committee we have a lot to get
to congressmen on these text messages
disappearing the secret society all of
it I want to get you first on this issue
of chain migration because I hear a lot
from Democrats about how Republicans are
now anti family congressman but as you
saw with that very difficult to read
graphic we are resettling huge
populations into the united states not
based on merit but based on distant
family relatives absolutely and they're
not even going to be reunified in any
short period of time because the amount
of the length of the waiting list is so
long that there's no real family
reunification our bill allows the
immediate family the spouse and minor
children to come into the United States
and that is very important for families
but these extended families do not
benefit the United States in the sense
that a merit-based system would where
people come here based upon education
job skills job offers and training
that's what we need in our economy not
people who are coming here based upon
random needs for our country and
ridiculous no it's it's preposterous
it's 400,000 plus people every year
coming in on this extended family chain
migration 400,000 it a complete scandal
I want to move to what's happening with
these revelations about the FBI that
disappearing text messages of course now
the understanding from an informant that
there was a secret society discussed and
text messages I'm not sure what secrets
they were talking about but doesn't
sound too good to me specifically the
text messages congressman how Joe
DeGeneres said on my radio show that the
NSA has every text message that we can
get those text messages if need be what
do you know about that we should search
every place to find them because I think
they still exist in some form somewhere
I'm pleased that attorney general
sessions has made a
to investigate this and find them but we
should also undertake whether there is
some way to gather them from some other
source it is very important but even the
text messages we have are alarming and
the secret society just harks back to
the the text we saw before in December
talking about the insurance policy what
has been going on in that five month
period of time well we know one thing
for sure and that is that these people
hostile to the president have not been
conducting themselves in a manner that
befits the Federal Bureau of
Investigation how does anyone have faith
in the integrity of the this
investigation congressman when we hear
that after in December we heard all text
messages had been turned over correct on
December 13th Congress was told you have
them all between struck and page in a
number of others as well then you guys
just learned oops we actually didn't
give you five months critical time
period of text messages and now we find
out secret society we find out you know
that you know all these people and
donating the Democrats connected to the
old administration how does the average
person think the FBI isn't cooking the
books here and I love so many of the
agents but at the upper levels of the
FBI well there is no question that there
are several people in headquarters that
we have a tremendous amount of questions
for and will be called some of them
we've already interviewed someone will
be calling back for further questioning
undoubtedly that will include former
director Comey it also is very true as
you say that the overwhelming majority
of the FBI works hard every day to keep
us safe to combat terrorism to to find
and convict criminals this is an
organization that is the premier law
enforcement the world and it is getting
dispersed by a few people and they need
to clean house there and and director
Ray has been told that by a number of
people do you have a point that we
haven't seen that do you have full faith
in director ray right now I think
director ray needs to show some
leadership in terms of responding to the
fact
that there is a crisis in the
headquarters of the FBI and changes need
be made and he could show that
leadership right now well why do you
think Andrew McCabe is still there after
everything we've learned about him the
deputy FBI director and apparently Jeff
Sessions according to reports leaned on
ready to get rid of them and Ray said
I'll quit
that's one report I'll quit if he goes
now what's that all about is there no
chain of command at the FBI that matters
I don't know I do understand that mr.
McCabe may be leaving very soon and if
that's the case that's one step but I
think the director has more work to do
and congressman before he let you go the
Muller investigation seems to be very
leaky over the last 24 hours we learned
that Jeff sessions had been called to
testify call me on that they're looking
to bring in the President to testify on
his firing of Comey and perhaps other
matters concerns about the leaks coming
out of this very high-profile very
important investigation when the
president seems to be getting good news
on other fronts such as the government
shutdown oh it's very concerning and
this is not a huge organization so you
would think that if you're operating an
unbiased impartial and effective
investigation you would have a control
over something as basic as leaks by the
relatively small number of people who
are doing that work for the special yeah
well it just indicates again there's an
animus toward the President and they're
leaking they're only leaking stuff for
the most part that you know is negative
toward the President and otherwise you'd
see leaks of ulta all times but
congressman thanks for staying on this
issue for us we'll check back with you
soon we really appreciate it